[Applause]
oh my God can you rip that in half and I
can use part like you you were so good
to me I was I really was like a lost
17-year-old I mean I was having so much
fun but like I didn't know how to take
care of myself and you took such good
care of me you were so kind to me and
like protected
me like so happy to see you incredible
what you did MH got you and and
incredible incredible Survivor I derit
was he was he really really took care of
me I mean I was wild guys like I was
really really wild sorry guys I cry
now it is so nice a man cry by but I
knew I was going
to and I came anyway and I decided I'm
going to go ahead and cry in public
yeah